I don't know why I just want a bucket of
fried chicken right now I have no idea
why I was just thinking what am I going
to do when I get off this podcast my
brain just said why don't you go out and
get a bucket of chicken you know what's
funny too it was a no-name brand too the
Colonel's face was not on the side it
was just a white bucket you already saw
the grease like clouds forming on the
outside of it you know what's the
greatest thing about eating a bucket of
chicken is not eating the chicken it's
the way you hold the bucket like a
newborn baby
I don't think there is any other greasy
food that feels the level of affection
before it's consumed like a bucket of
fried chicken
[Applause]